After the participant sections come the collaborations sections.
Collaboration is
how the participants work together to accomplish the pattern's goals.
The composite pattern is an example of a structural pattern.
One in which the organization of the information provides the primarily,
the primary value added.
For structural patterns, collaboration plays a less important role than
structure in providing information to the designer.
Nevertheless, understanding inter-element behavior is important.
For example, with the composite pattern,
a typical behavior is to have the composites iterate through their children,
performing some operation on each.